[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir je crois que le public t'a pris
pour quelqu'un d'autre par que tu as
énormément de succès que tu as
énormément de succès qui est ce sa que
vous scandz comme ça j'aimerais bien
savoir mais apparemment c'est toi fr
succèsour' il est très bon bah il passe
plus de temps au juv qu'au bureau
forcément merciment qu'il est bronzé le
non non attendez m'ont caché un char là
je vous raconte pas ouais ouais ah non
frère il est là ah mais j'ai vu tu une
sonnerie c'est des soushis on est en
bas c'est euh c'est s'il vous plaît on
est en bas c'est les sushis c'est quel
étage sur ma vie il a c'est l'interfan
c'est rougeement rouge je vous entends
pas ah il est
magnifique c'est des leson bas c'est la
pizza ah oui
[Applaudissements]
question pour un champion c'est un
bonheur auss non laisse-moi faire les
vannes t fait
tacron je vous laisse faire les v il y a
aucun problème Cyril je dois moi je
m'occupe des dossiers je m'occupe des
dossiers vous le savez je regarde tout
ce qui se passe pendant les pubes
pendant les offes pendant les magnetos
oui tuas un bout de saucisson qui
pousse tu veux de
l'Ariette non mais ça arrive à tout le
monde même au meilleurs ah cellelà elle
est lourde vous n'avez rien
allez vas-y juste un brdou
vas-y mais c'est d en fait j'en ai pas
moi chercher j'en ai pas part dans mon
cul donc tu vas pas venirir vas-y alors
vas-y donc je vous disais que moi je
m'occupe de ce qui se passe regarder
pendant les tu fais une tête bizarre bah
moi je peux les vérifier si tu veux
hein est il Devi Devi oh tu vas pas
faire des qu'est-ce que c'est que ça tu
dis que pas nager dans mon h j'adore
péter les boutons moi ah moi aussi
j'adore j'adore ça regard vidé sur
TikTok de boutons
per ai j'adore
j'adore ton mec nous regarde bah oui
mais il sait déjà que j'aime bien percer
le bouton de sa
cha tu veux que je disel c'est pas mal
parce qu'il commence à faire Grandin de
beauté c'est peut-être pas
mal il est pas ouf il est pas ouf
vraiment on va pas faire de plan dessus
parce
inro ça va
merci ou non non ça va ça va euh on va
rester sur sur mon bouton pendant une
heure
ou a pas dû le dire mais en fait en fait
quand on est riche on a pas de bouton ta
chronique fa ta
chronque oui bon ben alors il va fixer
mon bouton donc à part des boutons je
regarde à part avoir des boutons je
regarde ce qui se passe pendant les pubs
mais je pourquoi mais je je me peau est
grasse ma PE est grasse je suis gras
moiême ton épiderme est gras je te jure
ton épiderme gra ou il a pas un
complément sinon j'arrive comme ça même
avec un bouton tu es beau c'est sympa
c'est sympa donc c vous sa c'est pas une
varicelle
mais parce qu'à ce niveul quand même il
quand même c'est un gros B quand même je
peux faire une chronique d'armato si
vous voulez mais je suis là pour montrer
les dossiers donc évidemment je regarde
ce qui se passe les pubs mais je suis
Cyril partout et ça il ne le sait pas
oui même au chiot je vous suis partout
je suis allé au paddle cyil au paddle
oui je suis allé au paddle j'ai les yeux
partout et ben la semaine dernière et je
suis tombé sur une interview de
sachez un truc à la maison si vous avez
beau être le plus gentil du monde faire
le maximum de compliments à Cyril il
n'en a rien à [__] et il sera là pour
vous fracasser cyril est un gros tarbat
regardez la particularité de Cyril c'est
que c'est vrai que c'est c'est un joueur
mais bon après derrière c'est un ami
aussi donc du coup je suis obligé
de faire tout faire tout pour lui aussi
pour qu'il puisse accéder à son à son
objectif vraiment trop sympa ce coach
monsie John il vous fait plein de
compliments et franchement vous lui
rendez hyper bien ou pas et c'est des
choix qui sont très durs je sacrifie un
un frère
[Musique]
donc au niveau de la déception bon voilà
il l'a bien
pris
déception bâtard tu
es tu Le Rest merci j'embrasse John
le c'est le capitaine he le capitaine de
notre équipe et je voudrais dire merci à
John parce qu'il nous a amené très loin
puisque nous sommes champion champion de
France de N2 et oui on passe en N1
champion de France Merci Merci à merci
àa merci et ouais les chériis c'était un
beau weekend la semaine dernière bravo
et bravo à toute l'équipe bien entendu
très sympa cy là vous me voyez c'est
Sacha non je ne vois que ton bouton ah
vous voyez que mon bouton alors vous
voyez mon bouton Oui vous voyez mon
bouton c'est Michel Bing oui c'est
Michel Marie bonjour Michel qu'est-ce
que tu veux me dire Michel je suis à
l'interphone là comment allez-vous
Michel je suis en bas j'ai les soushis
je mon trou monte au 3è étage mais
seulement à 19h18 pas à
19h19 Michel Marie il fait du
faitérotisme mant je sais
pas sans rigoler oui alors c'est Michel
Marie il est 19h18 vous nous regardez à
la maison et j'ai quelque chose à vous
annoncer un fait d'hiver très sordide
j'ai une gadie j'ai une meuf oui Michel
Marie a une meuf ah oui c'est vrai on
l'embrasse Michel il est exceptionnel
qui physiquement franchement psartec
alors en réalité Guillaume Janton a
voulu faire croire cette semaine à rayon
que Michel Marie avait une meuf issue de
la téléréalité donc il a inventé une
histoire d'amour entre Michel et Léana
et Raymon a été très crédule il y a cru
alors pas tout le temps mais au début il
y a cru très fort regardez c'est la
bonne pomme de la
[Musique]
semaine tu as vu la meuf de tu as vu la
meuf de Michel Marie
al voici un petit visuel de l bonjour
madame cand de
téalitéion je te
jure
av maise Guillaum passe une étap il s
transformé en graphiste il a créé
unotontage juste pour
my les heres tu
VO je
dis bonà Guillaum vous l'avez vu il est
dans un vrai bourbier dans son mytho
fallait qu'il trouve une pour sortir
regarde son un follow sur insta cette
nuit mais ils étaient ensemble en 2 mois
a jamais froid en tout cas ouais c'est
pas
mal quel Mar c'est guaum Janton ça c'est
une merveille merci mon Saou c'est drôle
ça c'est très drôle C dans un instant
j'embrasse Michel qui est
exceptionnel et Ron embrasse Lana je
crois je suis invité à manger un pote
feu chez eux je suis invité à manger un
pote au feu chez eux c'est V en plus ais
Michel Marie m'a dit on va manger un
poteau feu ensemble je jure que c'est
vrai c'est pas une vane c'est la vérité
Michel Marie t'a invité à manger un po
vous jure sur la tête de mes ENF je
aller manger
asstoi vra on entrée on a donc une
salade
d'endive non ce sont des concombres
écoute c'est une salade Nive
g cy dans un instant on va recevoir
quelqu'un qu'on adore c'est Bertrand des
KERS Bertrand des KERS j'ai une info
pour vous C vous savez qu'il n'est pas
du tout né à Tunis il est né à serin en
Belgique j'ai l'impression qu'à chaque
fois qu'il est là vous avez envie de de
le ramener dans votre côté tunisien oui
vous fixez mon bouton mais je vous
assure que Bertrand Deckers vous vous
avez envie de de qu'il vienne tunisien
quoi oui je suis mieux avec ou sans il a
un cyclope comme ça c'estrai à chaque
fois que Bertrand des c'est là je ne
sais pas pourquoi cyil veut le rendre un
Tunisien alors qu'il est belge c'est le
Brito Brito Brito Brita tunisien la
semaine quo je vais y arriver qu'est-ce
que tu voulais dire je sais pas demande
mon bouton il va vous répondre tu sais
tu sais ce que tu dis tu comprends ta
chronique oui peu près près de temps en
temps bouton attaquer le cerveau
[Musique]
aussi tu sais ce que tu veux dire alors
pour revenir sur V
question elle a pas besoin non elle fait
pas manger elle fait
pas tout ça rien c'est vrai que en tout
cas
voilà ceux qui supportent
davantageet erre de parcours é formulé
par
har ser pas là je ser pas devant
vous elle AE les
bé
le spécice qu' manque lum Mme pas
sandwich mer
rien bon ça c'est la séquence préférée
de ma mère je vous dis en plus je crois
qu'elle a fait Makou ce
soir Ramor c'est que des plats tunisiens
ah ouais extraordinaire slata j slata
slata tout les slata c'est incroyable on
prend 10 kg mais c'est incroyable cyil
tu m tu veux manger chez ma mère avec
grand plaisir si je suis invité mais je
me laisse pas ma mère tout seule donc
c'est moi je vi tuas déjà une boulette
I du coup je on embrasse quand même
votre maman comme chaque semaine cy on
est on le Tarb de la semaine il y a un
instant on Ali le on a élu pardon on a
Éli ça va vousz pas me faire
chitation on a élu tout à l'heure en
fait c'est vra que tu es meilleur en
imitation donc on je pense qu'il y a des
mots qui sortent de ta bouche mais tu ne
les comprends pas oui mais c'est depuis
tout à l'heure vous êtes sur mon bouton
donc vous me perturbez pardon oui donc
on a tout à l'heure élu évidemment le
connard de la semaine
c'est unoper une grand frite un petit
cocin
[Applaudissements]
la mais où ça se passe à la télévision
un truc comme ça c'est pas possible ah
mer donc il y a quelques qu'est-ce qui
se passe bien ok donc il y a quelques
quelques minutes on a élu le connard de
la semaine c'était Jean-Michel là cette
fois on a oh là
là non mais fr non mais tu non mais tu
as arrêté l'école à qu non mais tu es
seul gars
turê qu'est-ce qui vous
arrive mon très bien frre tu pas pas de
mot mais non mais perturbe vous me
perturbez
incroyable c'est
incroyablecroable il est fragile
is petit fragile moi je suis un petit
fragile on a Ellie tout à
l'heure il est con ça va oh c'est bon ça
va il est con comme un
bouton le connard de la semaine mais qui
est le Tarba de la semaine ça commence
par Jean ça finit par Jean-Michel c'est
également Jean-Michel sachez que si il
vous aime sachez que si Jean-Michel vous
fait des compliments sachez que s vous
propose son aide et bien refusezla
puisqu'il vous fracasse par derrière
c'est le tarbat de la
[Musique]
SP de trouver des idées des idées
géniales t émion des expérien qui
trouvent rien il regardentis il
regardent mais com même pas je P
intitulé Comme ça bon en lisant ouis on
dirait une poule qui regarde un
couteau ça va dire ça va tu es en
détresse là je sens que tu es en
détresse là sil y a des trucs tu
comprends pas tu me
demandes il cherche il cherche un truc à
écriree il cherche une idée catastrophe
catastrophe oh là là là
là la police multiplie les saisies mais
ça ne sert à rien pour le moment le
phénomène est en expansion considérable
c'est le même problème que les
cigarettes les cigarettes clandestines
donc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci et j'embre for mon mundir que
j'aime qui sera de retour lundi et mardi
he voilà merci mon chéri mais un vrai B
plus j'espère que tu m'adoras jamais en
parlant de jean- Cyr va falloir vraiment
s'occuper de son cas puisque il croit
que toutes les meufs de la planète sont
à ses pied y compris les chroniqueuses
regardez ah c'est magnifique
j'aiimession parce qu' a un CR sur
moi une
[Applaudissements]
impression elle me regarde trop rarement
pour que ça soit
normal je regarde pass
asser je regarde asser je te regarde
passer ben non non mais c'est trop tard
maintenant maintenant
ça je te vois tu es en face de moi bon
très intéressant les de non mais non ça
pourrait être ton style ou pas oui non
mais pas
toi
pas toi toi Pascal est-ce que ça
pourraitêtre ton style Jean-Michel
honnêtement honnêtement hnêement non
mais tu es tu es tu es très beau
Jean-Michel mon
style quelqu'un dans ma vie tu vois mais
alors es sur une île déserte tu es sur
une île déserte ah ça y est c'est
reparti et
ou non mais il est très beau il est très
beau c'est ton St ou mais dit oui
on mon sty tu pourrais être avec lui ou
pas oui c'était célibataire si tu étais
célibe là vous l'obligez à dire oui mais
elle a
PASV
jalou ça fait plusieurs minutes
qu' est-ce que tu pourrais Ken avec
est-ce que tu pourrais Ken ave attends
moi je con pas comme ça moi mais oh
c'est de la tour du P là ou tu as vu
comment il y a de beau dans son nom là
quelquun comme ça frère il y a plus de
nom dans son nom dans son nom que
sur le conducteur frère non non non mais
ça pour être ta cam mais je écoutez il
faudrait qu'on discute qu'on parle déjà
déjà quand une meuf dit ça quand une meu
dit ça qu
tu c'est unenvironnement il elle a pas
d'environnement son style si tu es sur
une île désert tu prends Raymon
ou sur
déser pas de maladie pas de maladie
vraiment O c'est pour moi il y a pas
photo quand même oh là non mais
alors
jemich
qu ça fait mal ça fait très mal sur
une fait du monde et toi galdine tu
viens m
comme j'en ai rien à [__] je viens
quand
même laisse tomber c'est comme ma sœur
Pascal c'est pas la question hein si si
quoi bah si non mais c'est vrai que
Géraldine toi tu réponds jamais à ces
truc moi quelqu'un se retrouve sur une
île déserte avec moi c'est ça ça sera
pas pour aller cuillir des noixs de coco
hein je te le dis je t'explique c'est
pas la peine qu'elle vienne voilà c'est
une amie c'est pas la peine qu'elle
vienne voilà vas-y avec jeanm hein voilà
je là moi c'est qui
jeis rien fa rien prochaine exactement
il fait rien la semaine prochaine bah
oui vous l'avez vu Jean vois des crushes
partout y compris Pascal alors que je
Traille pas un secret vous l'avez vu on
a rien à
foutreme du coup se rabat sur qui et là
c'est grave c sur qui sur le public non
et
ça Mo m' moi je m'en vais hor je le dis
au téléspectateurs je le dis au
téléspectateurs j'ai un cas de
conscience par non j'ai besoin de parler
au téléspectateurs et au public j'ai
besoin de parler au téléspectateur
public je n'ai pas vu cette séquence
mais j'étais tranquillement en et je
voyais des choses se passer ou
qui ne m'ont pas plus
je cache pas là ne mont pas plus ces
choses là je demande au public est-ce
que vous voulez
que
bctol fraise est-ce que vous voulez que
bctol que
[Rires]
BCT je te voisici tuas un grain roufflé
ici est-ce que vous voulez que CR
[Rires]
excusez-moi cy dans quelle société vous
avez un patron qui vous appelle crun
parce que vous avez un bouton CR tu peux
venir dans mon bureau s'il te plaît euh
dites-moi donc est-ce que vous voulez
que
crunch
enchanté passe ce Magnetto qui peut être
extrêmement
problématique
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas non mais public
évidemment je suis payé pour ça et quand
je vais balancer le Magneto profitez de
Jean-Michel dans cette émission puisque
c'est le charot de la semaine vous allez
voir c'est très très grave sa quo parler
est-ce que est-ce que tu penses qu'il
faut le passer moi je pense que ce
serait très très grave pour jeanm qu'
merci merci vraiment vraiment ouais
vraiment ouais vraiment bah oui oui
c'est un briseur de ah c'est de
tout un briseur de hanche vous êtes sûr
qu'on peut le passer ce Magneto alors je
suis sûr mais avertissement du cô
tpectateur qui voudrait venir dans
l'émission quand vous ins
sur je d'abord faire un tour de table
pour ceux qui sont au courant du Magneto
enfin de ceux qui sont courant de de ce
qui s'est passé ça c'est une pépite ou
tu es bien au courant moi j'ai tout vu
du début jus tout
entenduou il m'a pris en témoin j'ai
tout vu j'ai tout entendu c'est vraiment
très très très très grave néanmoins je
suis pas pour qu'on le passe ouais parce
que c'est je suis un peu solidaire avec
jeanm mais pour les téléspectateurs
téléspectateurs il faut le passer il
faut le
passer je crois que Gill g JAAC que vous
êtes les deux autres témoins euh vous
avez tout Vuul moi j'ai tout vu c'est
grave et j'aime beaucoup jeanmis donc il
faut le
passer non non non taisez-vous
taisez-vous s'il vous plaît je sais que
vous voulez pas qu'on le passe ouais
vous voulez vraiment que je le passe B
je sa c'est Mo je peux pas Mo très bien
musique très bien de quoi Ren j'ai le
cul propre ouais bon ben ouais on n pas
parlé du derrière on a parlé du devant
pareil Jack moi je pense que c'est une
affaire très très grave non mais arrêtez
je suis vraiment pas loin de Jean-Michel
donc je vois tout ce qui se passe avir
une AM av d'avoir montré les images de
complément qui va faire un complément je
suis désolé pour toi jeanmis parce que
je t'aime bien mais je pense que pour la
transparence de l'émission n diffus
transparence je suis l ce magnéto me
pose problème mais qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous C moi j'ai je l'ai engueulé
sais je l' envoyé chier je vais vous
expliquer un petit peu le
contexte il y avait une jeune fille dans
le public non mais je dis rien ok il une
jeune fille dans le public oui et
Jean-Michel est
avenant un peu trop un peu
trop en ce moment vous dit je suis à
venant non je suis à V sur Marne en ce
moment pass on va le passer si tu crois
qu' a pas le
choix tu un
connard et en plus pardon chtien non non
dis-nous dis-nous dis-nous est-ce que il
est grave parce que j'ai rien vu moi en
fait j'ai sa pas V
temps là non non on a le temps
t'inquiète pas on a le tempson oui
est-ce qu'on met ou pas alors si c'est
que mon avis vous me payez pour
rapporter des dossiers je pense que
c'est l'un des plus gros dossiers de
l'histoire de l'indic de laaredac
ou
attend je vous dis même moi j'ai vu que
des bribes et je suis pas à l'aiseuss je
suis pas tu à l'aise toiis pas à l'aise
ça avoir des répercussions énormes sur
quoi oui sur des choses des gens et le
public c'est le public le public quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il y a donc vous pensez que
lui non il a vraiment il y a vraiment eu
des il aura pas de il aura rien lui mais
arrête c'est pas faiter
l'accusé pas encore pas
encore faites attention c quoi c'est
vrai non sans rigoler B peut-être faut
manner ça avec précaution ouais vous
pensez que c'est compliqué parce que moi
vous avez tout vu moi j'ai tout vu aussi
tout entendu alors pas tout entendu
parce que j' plus près que moi mais j'ai
suffisamment vu pour être impressionné
moi il m'a interpellé il m'a dit viens
là-bas faut que je te parle il m'a
emmené carrément dans le couloir là-bas
pour me parler ch les Chéries ma
déontologie fait que ce Magneto vous le
verrez dans quelques instants euh sach
base euh est-ce que vous pouvez
expliquer à nos téléspectateurs et ceux
qui nous rejoignent nombreux à 19h43
maintenant ce qui quand c'était
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé est-ce qu'on
va voir alors ce qu'on va voir donc je
je je présente les coulis de l'émission
ce qui se passe pendant les pubs et ce
qui s'est passé c'est que Jean-Michel
Jean-Michel a fait quelque chose de très
grave pendant les pub Jean-Michel est un
gros coquin il n'a pas réussi avec
Pascal il s'est rabattu sur une membre
du public Cyril c'était cette semaines
et il a dragué quelqu'un ouvertement
mais le pire c'est qu'elle était en
couple AE AE
a
j'ai déjà des messages j'ai déjà des
messages de gens qui plent de
[Musique]
vous dans public mais un me ça vame il
est HN pas du tout
Chac
tilémo la tte de coffeuse qui est tout
et franchement il y a de
quoi attends dis-moi le numéro je
l'yé
[Musique]
[Rires]
le prénom Jen Jennifer ok ok je trouve
comment on fait in the
[Musique]
pocket on embrasse très fort Jennifer
c'est B c'est bon c'est bon arrête ne
l'fluz pas on on embrasse très fort
Jennifer voilà et et bien sûr son son
financé avec qui je parlais est très
sympathique voilà
exactement du tout lui lui bien sûr j'ai
discuté avec lui plus qu'avec elle ser
c'est ser disc avec excuse-toi je peux
montrer parce que je lui envoyé la photo
je peux montrer qu'elle m'a renvoyer un
message en me disant merci beaucoup pour
la photo je n'ai pas répondu après ah
ouais j'ai la preuve dans mon téléphone
he facile de supprer me demander de
regarder mais je
peux je quand même regarder ça tout à
l'heure allez sal Ciao